dans le village les fleurs et les
couleurs ne suffisent plus à dissimuler
les traces de la pandémie peur de venir
comme pendant la pandémie un petit peu
la cour des miracle c'était un petit peu
qu'on effectivement mais là en fait
juste de faire Berry Baudry à pied je me
suis fait quitter à peu près 10 fois les
résidents les commerçants et les
visiteurs ont été sondés au cours de
l'été maintenant c'est au tour des
organismes communautaires et commerciaux
de plancher sur l'avenir de leur
quartier des discussions qui se tiennent
à la veille d'importants travaux sur les
réseaux d'aqueduc et des goûts prévus
sur la rue Sainte-Catherine Est en 2024
le désir qu'on donne une cure de
jouvence sur une cure de jeunesse à
notre à notre rue Sainte-Catherine les
défis sont grands plusieurs locaux sont
vacants et il a fallu déployer davantage
de travailleurs de rue et d'intervenants
sociaux pour aider les populations
vulnérables nombreuses dans le secteur
et confront un manque de service c'est
sûr qu'on a un défi de cohabitation
c'est vraiment l'enjeu qui revient le
plus souvent quand on parle à nos
membres cet aspect de sécurité dans la
rue Sainte-Catherine c'est travailleuse
de rue espère que les discussions
permettront un véritable dialogue entre
les parties quand on met du nouveau
immobilier urbain mais que ça soit du
mobilier inclusif et donc du mobilier ou
les gens peuvent dormir on pense au
fameux banquiers itinérant qu'on veut
pas nécessairement un quartier trouver
une vision commune sera toutefois tout
un jeu d'équilibriste reconnaît le
responsable de l'urbanisme l'objectif
c'est comment on est capable de réanimer
cet espace là mais en faisant en sorte
que on ne fasse pas de
l'éco-gentrification il faudra notamment
attirer de nouveaux commerçants
boucherie une fromagerie un fleuriste un
endroit pour faire du coworking sans
pour autant effacer les marqueurs
identitaires et les commerces de niche
qui ont forgé durant des décennies
l'identité du village ici Camille
Radio-Canada Montréal